okay cool hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to continuously
no a while ago I played a game called
continuous it was an endless hallway
game a lot like Silent Hill PT in fact
that came out soon after that was
released and while PT might still be
canceled or at least in development
limbo I wouldn't give up too much hope
I've heard rumors on the rumor mill that
maybe something else is gonna be made
out of it or at least something will be
inspired by it but in the meantime I
don't know if this game has anything to
do with any of that oh boy now I know
that I said in the intro there was a
boarded up second floor
this looks diabolical I've never walked
up a staircase before so I'm in a
trapped abandoned building and I'm not
gonna be able to go anyway I just had a
flashback does everyone remember SCP uh
oh god the stairwell I can't I can never
remember the numbers of those but the
stairwell game that I played a long long
time ago as you said a weird flashback
to that hello oh excuse me never mind
then hello oh that's how it's gonna be
it is like hey don't be flashing like
that it is like PT it is oh hi wait is
this upside down or is that a floor lamp
hmm I can't even run so this is the pace
that it's gonna set for me oh wow I
wonder what's in store and I wonder why
can't I go in that door on the second
floor I really want some more I don't
mean to be a bore
oh this is starting to become a chore
the store must be kept locked lies and
slander cuz apparently I'm gonna be
looping back and forth forever okay you
can keep doing that whatever you want
bring it on if something gonna be
brought eventually please some brought
it miss some bring a tude
what the [ __ ] oh okay nothing yeah I
should have known it never opens up with
something in these games it always opens
up with a whole lot of nothing
was that a sousaphone or was that a
monster I can never tell the difference
hey it's not being in different places
and he was war right then is that
getting more and more boarded up I
believe it is yes I'm supposing that's
symbolizing oh I believe that's getting
less and less boarded up ah so it's more
porting up so that I can be trapped in
here and not so much that it's gonna be
able to let me out all right bring it on
somebody wait why can't I go crap I
can't open that door oh boy
somebody else here somebody better bring
dude we're gonna bring it on okay well
this seems oh is that the thumpy thump
of the Slenderman something tells me I
don't want to go in here oh boy oh okay
yeah I'll get real close to this don't
read it young yeah was brutally murdered
in the stairwell section of the floor to
maintenance area cameras captured an
alley entering the room but never came
out is still currently I know cuz we're
dead I don't believe they've seen a
black figure sunburn the windows do
engine air now blocked off dude and
man's access to the building stated okay
all right I was under the assumption
that there might be something behind me
okay cool nothing Abbot I'm okay Oh
oh you bastard oh you better let me out
of here you better let me out I'm like a
wild animal when I'm cornered I cry like
you wouldn't even believe where do I go
now
is that me whimpering am i Analia wifey
Analia I don't remember it being that
squeaky before but okay at least I have
the sweet taste of freedom oh boy I
can't wait to meet whatever murderer
comes massively murdering my way oh no
ohh anymore can I go through here now
thank you
I'd rather loop through with one more
time please oh it got a little more
pleasant the floor lamp on the bottom is
gone you know I have yet to what it was
that always there before I have yet to
see any shadowy figure that it said
before that is a pleasant noise why am I
going in the second floor one again I
don't even know if I want to go okay it
knows you're here I know I'm here
remember don't look behind you it's the
mistake
[Music]
nee-naw well there it is
I was wondering oh boy mr. scratchy
fingers is over there is that salad
fingers [ __ ] I was in the middle of
swallowing don't take that out of
context oh hi
well you've come to greet me cool go
away I need to go somewhere else please
[Music]
all right let's see what new note is in
here don't look behind you it's standing
right behind you're gonna murder you at
any moment
[Music]
he cut me open
he cut me open he cut who open who cut
who me I can't close that door he tried
to close that door well now it's just
getting a little weird
why is there baby why is the baby having
a conniption why is everything in this
why is any oh god more lamps exactly
what I needed more illumination Oh
see what else we got in store for me
another new note of loveliness I'll see
you oh good see me so hard oh this one's
red now I know I'm the PT demo this one
got red too hello some monstrosity gonna
jump out of me I'm totally ready exposed
in everything
come on stop sniffing oh hey did not
notice you they're worried about the
sniffing going on what are you doing you
running away from me and my the monster
well then you were big you're bigger
than I thought
in hell I knew it I called it I'll see
you in Hell kind of hard to see him when
he's pitch black and everything else can
you shut up baby
damn it baby I'd be a bad bad apparently
I know I think I'd be a good oh it's
back to normal
never mind that was short-lived at least
the baby finally showed up
Wow lovely we're getting close to the
end here cuz I know that in the original
continuous game two kind of went on
forever until you just got to that last
room and you couldn't go any further
[Music]
missing
as I know working okay so well alright
then that was a thing see he took my
baby the noises he made they drove me
mad I've never heard my babies make such
noises before neither have I that's why
I told it to shut up
cuz I knew it was some demon baby and
why how and why he told me that I would
never leave no matter how long I walked
how far I went it just never ended I
know the feeling I definitely know the
feeling in the end he just put it to an
end is he gonna kill me
is that my end is that the end you're
talking about here let me prepare for
[Music]
let's see I suppose it's time to put an
end to this as well they grew quite fond
of you but sadly it's time to move on
okay cool
what does that mean you're gonna murder
me you're gonna murderlize me he is
coming
well I'm ready for him in more ways than
one oh god damn it
I see that reality is starting to unfold
good thing I can't run or anything my
baby oh I'm back here now okay alright
then
whoopty doopty do someone pick up that
phone all I wanted to do was buy him a
lamp for his new room just too bright up
the place so in the end I bought 27 I
hope he likes it but in the end the
other end he was blinded by the light he
is here oh really
in here no he's not bunch of liars
you're bunch of liars
lies lies and slander stop scratching up
the walls
stop being a creeper stop stop pretty
much everything you're doing hello
I can't have a flat say he is here where
I don't see him oh I think you're just a
joking hmm where is he okay I guess
that's it
yay all right that was pretty good that
was not bad at all I mean obviously it
was limited you know technically and
graphically wise but it was still pretty
cool concept I mean the whole concept of
PT was really interesting not because
you know it was linear or anything and
some people said it was very linear and
yes in some ways it was but it was also
like unique everyone had their own way
of going about it and even I haven't
even seen the ending of it because I got
frustrated and I didn't want to give up
and look it up so I still don't know
what the ending is or how to get there
but either way this was fun
a quite a few jump scares a little bit
of an interesting twist on things and
not so bad you can play this game for
yourself with the link in the
description below let me know what you
thought of in the comments as well and
as always thanks for watching and as
always I'll see you
[Music]
oh no baby no no baby no no